et on a parmi le public camille qui est
qui a guéri de lakovic 19 un jour et
qu'elle se lève
camille quand est-ce que vous avez
contracté
oui je pense que ça marche si vous
mettez dessous quand est-ce que vous
avez contracté la maladie
alors j'ai attrapé le coronavirus en
mars avec des problèmes respiratoires
j'ai pas été hospitalisé parce qu'il
jugeait le manque akpa critique en fait
je pense surtout parce qu avait pas
assez de places dans les hôpitaux du
pouilly ils sélectionnés par rapport à
ça je suis suivi vous avez la sensation
que j'avais eu de la place on aurait
hospitalisé hier là je suis suivie
actuellement par abd homoud logue qui
m'a confirmé que si l'aja décontracté
maintenant avec le symptôme que j'ai
eues j'aurais été hospitalisé quoi moi
jaguar match et que donc voila et avec
des séquelles maintenant j'avais des
séquelles neurologiques g que je n'ai
plus j'avais
j'étais très fatigué un problème de
concentration aussi
et là j'ai des problèmes respiratoires
je suis comme si j'étais asthmatiques
sévère donc je cite je suis un
traitement matin et soir je peux plus
faire de sport
dès que je suis essoufflée j'ai des
injections faites d'adrénaline à me
faire et ça a été sévère tout de suite
chez vous c'était sévère tout de suite
chez vous les symptômes a les symptômes
ouais ouais ouais c'est en fait j'ai eu
vent des locaux vides
et je pense trois semaines un mois après
j'ai commencé à avoir les symptômes
ça a commencé par la fatigue et après
par les la respiration et là je suis
encore sur i par un pneumologue encore
quelques temps enfin c'est pas moi qui
ai une petite progression quand même je
le vois moins qu'avant je suis je le
voyais toutes les trois semaines à peu
près là ça mais qu'est ce que vous dit
le pneumologue que c'est un sujet qui
peut durer vraiment très longtemps il
c'est pas ça qui voit une amélioration
après il ya une comparaison par rapport
à d'autres cas mais pour le moment c'est
pas c'est une nouvelle maladie en commun
ils apprennent au fur et à mesure du
coup chez un peu un test
voilà donc une cobaye pour les cobayes
non est-ce que vous savez comment vous
l'avez contracté la maladie
papa trop déjà je suis quelqu'un qui est
je suis casanière mai donc je n'ai pas
chopé en soirée c'est sûr et certain à
penser bonnes réponses
ouais je pense et plus dans les
transports en commun je suis sur la
ligne 13 pour la prendre c'est celle ci
après aussi je roulais pour ceux qui
sont pas parisien c'est une line pas
également redoutable parce que les frais
chargés en parallèle je revenais d'un
voyage humanitaire
donc est-ce que je n'ai pas attrapé au
maroc parce que c'est au moment où les
frontières
pardon frontières fermées et c'est vrai
que pendant près de 48 heures ont été
les uns sur les autres à macao à
l'aéroport donc qu'est-ce que je
l'attrapé là bas je sais pas en tout cas
c'était une petite semaine après mon
retour de marrakech et docteur ès qu' on
peut attraper deux fois le co vie alors
je vous l'assuré là aussi pas mal de
réponses contradictoires a déjà c'était
le métro en mars dont on porter pâle
mars le masque qui aura pas relancé la
polémique sur les transports en commun
il y attrape eu beaucoup de virus et de
votre question c'est est ce qu'on peut
l'attraper
le foyer quelques cas rarissime
effectivement des cris ou des janves
aurait vraiment fait deux formes
symptomatiques de covin mais ça reste
l'exception pour l'instant et c'est le
constat transmettre non loin est ce qu
elle peut transmettre parce que
justement les personnes qui ont déjà été
positifs qui ont déjà eu le virus est ce
que du coup ils peuvent se libérer du
match mais là cela ça n'a aucun rapport
à la vous avez des symptômes post que
vides
vous ne portez plus le virus alors ok
c'est ma question c'est à dire s'il ya
des gens dont parce que ceux qui l'ont
jamais eue on peut l'attraper ils
transmettent on peut être asymptomatique
on sait pas nous sommes un peu un péril
pour les autres mais ce qu'ils ont déjà
eu et qui ne transmettent plus eu
pourquoi on les libère pas du masque ah
mais c'est une bonne question
docteur en question les questions
entourent ce titre choc priori hambourg
est auteur ceux qui recherchent les
virus sont des gens qui n'ont pas
sécrété d'anticorps c'est ça non non on
n'en sait rien paris celui décrit et
quand on a des anticorps sait pour
combien de temps non c'est parce qu'à
chaque fois je vois un médecin je lui
pose des questions et je remarque et ça
c'est pas la faute de la victime c'est
quelque chose comme de nouveaux qui
apparaît que les réponses sont rarement
les mêmes ça ne coïncident quasiment
jamais